Though they have years of experience under
their belts, our MCU favorites aren't immune
to making mistakes on the job. Such is the
case for the cast of Avengers: Endgame, who
goofed up a handful of times while filming
the superhero blockbuster. Here are some of
our favorite Endgame bloopers and outtakes.
Oh, Chris Pratt. Arguably the goofiest of
the three Chrises in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, the charismatic guy who plays Star-Lord
is known for getting the giggles going on
set — even in a movie with as much emotion
and intensity as Endgame. While preparing
to face off against Thanos in the film's epic
third act, Pratt offers a hilarious piece
of advice to keep the actors safe during shooting.
"Nobody pull a hamstring! Warm your butt cheeks
up. Warm up your butt cheeks!"
Later in the Endgame blooper reel, Pratt provides
more laughs when he stops to fix his hair
between takes.
Fat Thor, officially known as "Bro Thor,"
was a prominent part of Endgame, with many
arguing about the purpose and potential negative
consequences of portraying the God of Thunder
with a plumper physique, an increased love
for beer and candy, and a gloomier outlook
on life. It turns out that sticking ripped
Aussie actor Chris Hemsworth in a fat suit
and a bunch of heavy prosthetics allowed for
many antics to happen while shooting Endgame,
including this fun moment with a Rocket Racoon
stand-in ...
Robert Downey Jr. is the focus of many Endgame
bloopers, starting with the slip-up that occurred
when he was filming a scene at the S.H.I.E.L.D.
base in the 1970s while attempting to get
his hands on the Tesseract after the Avengers
failed to retrieve it from 2012 New York.
Everything goes mostly according to plan,
with Tony Stark and Steve Rogers doing their
best to blend in and complete their high-stakes
mission. Tony ends up making his way to the
Tesseract, snagging it, sticking it in his
briefcase, and heading back to the year 2023
to load up the Avengers' Infinity Gauntlet
and bring back the billions of people Thanos
dusted.
In one take of the scene in which Tony retrieves
the Tesseract, Downey Jr. reaches out to grab
the glowing blue cube that holds the Space
Stone… and then pulls a little too hard
"I broke it."
Scarlet Witch actress Elizabeth Olsen took
a tumble on set as she shot the heroine's
vengeance-tinged sequence at the end of the
film. The moment happened while Olsen's Scarlet
Witch was making her way toward Thanos to
unleash the full capacity of her mystical
powers and give him a piece of her mind. The
theatrical version of that scene was impactful
enough to send shivers down every viewers'
spines, but one take saw Olsen slip and fall
before she could reach the Mad Titan.
The time travel in Avengers: Endgame is difficult
to wrap your head around. Paul Rudd, whose
superhero character Ant-Man knows plenty about
time travel, alternate dimensions and how
to navigate the Quantum Realm, got a bit flustered
while trying to explain the rules of time
travel as outlined in Endgame.
"The thing about time travel…"
In another Endgame outtake, Captain America
actor Chris Evans laughs over the mask he
wore in 2012's Avengers, which he apparently
now thinks is dorky or maybe uncomfortable.
"I can't believe I made a whole movie with
this thing on.
In another blooper, Captain Marvel star Brie
Larson admits that she doesn't feel cool while
wearing a bald cap and hanging from a harness
for a scene in which her character is flying.
“Yeah. Does it look cool, or? It doesn't
feel cool, but if it looks cool, that's what
matters."
Shooting a film as monumental as Avengers:
Endgame works up a mighty appetite, and the
stars were apparently thinking of snacks and
sugary sodas while on set.
"Do you have any idea what's coursing through
my veins right now?"
"Funyuns?"
"Yes!"
Another Endgame blooper shows Ancient One
portrayer Tilda Swinton asking for an orange
soda while shooting. Right on cue, up pops
a hand with a glass bottle of the fizzy stuff.
Thanos wasn't the only enemy Tony Stark had
to face off against in Avengers: Endgame.
Actor Robert Downey Jr. faced some trouble
with the automatic trunk of Tony's sleek sports
car while trying to shut it before heading
into Avengers HQ.
"We are getting the whole team, aren't we?
F---a duck!"
From losing his wife and children in Thanos'
Decimation at the start of the film to taking
on the moniker Ronin and going on a revenge-fueled
killing spree and watching his fellow Avenger
Black Widow die in front of his eyes, Hawkeye
had a dark storyline in Avengers: Endgame.
However, the actor who plays the sharp-shooting
hero had a lot of fun on set.
The Endgame blooper reel ends just as the
Infinity Saga did: with Iron Man. Actor Robert
Downey Jr. is the last face fans see in the
collection of goof-ups, shown shooting the
scene in which he returns to 2012 New York.
Part of that portion of the Avengers' time
heist mission involved Tony Stark disguising
himself as a law enforcement officer responding
to the chaos in Stark Tower. While filming
that sequence, Downey Jr. jokes that every
take he's delivered has been flawless and
that he simply can't improve upon perfection:
We know RDJ is just being silly, but there's
some truth to his quip. His Iron Man was the
hero who laid the foundation for the MCU,
and without him, the Marvel movie world wouldn't
be what it is today.
"I feel like I've given you all you could
ever want."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU flicks are coming soon. Subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one.